good evening it's a great honor to
welcome to welcome you all tonight at
Columbia University on behalf of the
blinkin European Institute and the
middle Conn says on the occasion of the
recent publication of Toma pika cheese
capital in the 21st century
closer okay he may give superfluous to
introduce Thomas director of studies at
the Ecole des altitudinal social in
Paris and the founder of the a cold
economy the party or even the book since
so much has been said in the past few
weeks about both but let me summarize in
a few words paraphrasing somewhat what
Thomas says in his introduction the in
the it's very own introduction of his
book he is a story a young brilliant
economist who had produced a few
equations for his PhD dissertation gets
hired by a world-class American
University he realizes that he doesn't
know much about anything and he goes
back to all Europe all these amasai
happens between the age of 22 and 25 to
renew with a more historical and
sociologically informed informed way of
understanding economy one that insists
on historical dynamics rather than
formalization and one that considered
that political processes rather than I'm
sorry are not igloo genus but integral
to these dynamics this leads him to
spend a few years in the basement of the
French tax administration to analyze tax
returns over a century and to the
publication of the already very large
lake evening of homes of Anton Zeck
published in 2001 which analyzes the
dynamic of wealth distribution in France
throughout the 20th 20th century the
next step is the broadening of the
history of wealth repartition
mostly in Europe and the United States
with Anthony Atkinson and Emanuel sells
a work which directly inspired the
coining of the phrase the one percent
finally
having learned a few things our
economy's produces a major book entitled
capital in the 21st century actually I'm
going to show the French version because
it was the book he wrote was actually
the capital of anti-union SEC which was
just translated in English after just
after a few months of the publication in
French that book follows the dynamics of
capital in the beginning of the 20th of
the 19th century revisiting some of the
central theoretical claims of Ricardo
MUX and coos nets and not shying from
the insights of Jane Austen basic or
nagging my foods this book is monumental
in terms of the historical and
theoretical scopes it does offer some
very clear and strong thesis about the
forces of convergence and divergence
that animate capitalism today it does so
based on a very robust historical
demonstration and finally it proposed a
very clear and powerful political
program to regulate contemporary capital
in the light of these three major themes
we have invited three panelists whose
own work lies at the intersection of
economy history and politics after a
presentation of about 20 minutes by Tom
a Piketty of the main thesis of this
book each of our panelists will offer a
few comments first to speak will be
Thomas IDO a professor of journalism at
Columbia and a columnist for The New
York Times who comments regularly on
major trends in American politics and
with the author most recently of the
edge of austerity our second speaker
will be Victoria de gracia more ecology
ecology professor of history was written
extensively about the political and
social history of Europe a new zest
letters book irresistible Empire
America's advance throughout 20th
century Europe was published in 2005
finally our last speaker tonight will be
storage Nadeau
who did his PhD at Berkeley and studies
political and economic history and who
has been teaching at Columbia
School of International and public
affairs since 2010 after their
presentation and questions we love about
Tama will have about 10 to 15 minutes
for answer them and then finally we'll
open the room for discussion with the
room thank you so much
it's ank you Thank You Manuel and thank
you everybody for being here so you know
I'm very glad to talk about this book
today so sorry the book is a bit too
long and I should have you know managed
to keep it shorter but I guess you know
the book is really trying to put a lot
of historical material together so you
know this takes a lot of space because
the scope is very broad and let me say
right away that you know the book is a
single author and I am solely
responsible for the mistakes that may be
in the book but the book was really on a
very much a collective research process
okay so I could never have collected all
this data on my own so the my first work
and France and and this book was
published erm and since then you know I
was really fortunate to have many
cultures and collaborators with Toni
Atkinson the work was extended to
Britain with the manual says to the u.s.
to respect into alvarado to Argentina
with Jill post elimination or dental
gabriel zucman we worked on historical
evolution of wealth rather than income
and and you know there are I cannot
possibly quote them all but you know
there are over 50 people that have been
involved in the construction of this
historical database and income and
wealth and which is you know at this
stage the larger to existing historical
database on this issue so this is still
very imperfect you know we still not
little and you know but at least we know
a little bit more than than before and
in this book the main purpose of this
book is simply to present this evidence
in a consistent manner so there's also a
part for about you know policy
conclusion for the future but you know
let me say very clearly that you can
very well disagree with everything
that's in pass for and still you know
find some interest in part 1 2 and 3 and
which really tells the story of income
and wealth and try to set the facts so
you know I'm just like all of you you
know I am better at analyzing the past
signs of future and you know I the
proposal the policy conclusions that I
draw in part four strike me as the most
reasonable but you know I don't claim
that they are the only possible
conclusion and ultimately the objective
is to you know give to everybody the
information that could help them to
write their own platform and you know I
don't have no you know I think we have
to be very modest on this issue there's
no way we can test perfectly all the
ipod edges and of course there's no way
one can predict exactly what the future
values of you know the world growth rate
and the world rate of return to capital
will be in the next century that would
be crazy so you know I I don't have at
all this deterministic view of the
future that some people seem to be in
some of the reviews and and you know I
think there are many different possible
futures depending on particular hundred
policy and institutions that we choose
so this book relies on two big set of
data one about income and the other one
that is even more important about wealth
so the income part comes from the world
type income database which is a database
that we've constructed with all these
cursors and and so the countries in red
are in the database the countries in
blue are about in the database so being
in the database means that we've used
all the historical income data available
in particular since the creation of the
income tax in each particular country so
the income tax was created in 1913 in
the United States in 1914 in France 1909
in return in its modern progressive from
1922 in India you know in number of X
colonies X colonial power introduced in
contact with you early so we have
historical data on income so the typical
output of this database is this kind of
graph so
for the United States where so we find
you know we have this large reduction in
the share of national income going to
the top 10% between the 1920s and the
1950s so this is actually exactly what
Kuznets found in the 1950s and all what
we've been doing is to add another Alpha
century but of course this changes quite
substantially and also Kuznets only one
country and we have over 30 countries
but to a large extent what we've been
doing is just to extend the methods and
and work done by Canadian refugees so
the conclusions of course are that you
get with that supplementary data the
conclusions are quite different so in
the 50s 60s Kuznets at this conclusion
saying that you know in the advanced
stages of economic development you have
a reduction and then you know
stabilization of inequality you know to
be honest cosmetic himself was not too
convinced by the spontaneity of this
mechanism but I guess in the you know
Cold War period there was you know many
strong reason why people wanted to be
optimistic and wanted to believe in IP
and about the story of inequality and
capitalism now when we have the recent
the most recent decade you know you can
see the picture is quite different I
have not put on this graph the latest
data point for 2012 which we've put a
line with Emmanuel Saez recently and
where the latest data point is above 50
percent for the process seems to be
continuing where is it going to stop you
know nobody knows you know so some
people seem to believe that you know
wherever it will stop will be fine but
you know the given the magnitude of the
trend I think it's reasonable to to you
know ask the question you know is this
you know is this really useful for
growth you know the growth performance
of the US economy over the recent period
since 1980 has not been particularly
good so if you if you have 1.5 percent
per capita GDP growth and 2/3 or 3/4 of
it goes to the top 10% and mostly
top 1% you know it's not clear that this
is really a good deal for the rest of
the population so you know that's an
issue that I analyzed in the book and I
try to analyze you know the reason for
this you'd rise particularly of top
managerial compensation now although
this is included in the book this is not
the main part in the book and the book
tries to shift the attention from this
evolution of top incomes to the
evolution of wealth concentration per se
because I you know I believe both issues
are important and to some extent they
you know the rise of top incomes feeds
into the rise of top wealth but the
dynamics of wealth distribution and
wealth accumulation follow also you know
additional logic and processes and and
in particular you know there's been a
long-run recovery of aggregate wealth to
income ratio which you're going to see
you know in this picture for European
countries so you know it looks a little
bit like the u-shape picture that we
have here except that it's a completely
different process and in fact this
happens mostly in Europe and Japan
whereas the previous one is mostly in
the United States so the previous one
was about the share of total income
going to top 10% income although now
this curve is not about inequality
strictly speaking this is about the
aggregate quantity of net private wealth
to national income you know it could be
you know you could have a lot of capital
relative to income without inequality
you know if everybody has an equal share
in the capital stock so this does not
necessarily imply a rise of inequality
and and this is certainly not bad in
itself you know to have a lot of capital
you know after all it's better to have a
lot of capital that were just a lot of
debt and and you know right now people
are you know worried about public debt
and private that you know it's important
to be aware of the fact that rich
countries and in particular European
countries are rich you know their
governments are - which is a different
matter but you know the net private
wealth has never been as large you know
for almost a century
and so you know there has been a big
decline
aggregate net private wealth following
the world wars and you have a strong
recovery starting in the 1950s and and
and now we are know seem to be going
back to the kind of very I was to income
ratio that we had in European societies
prior to World War one so there are
three main points that you know I would
like to make instrumentation then you
know I'm gonna try to go really that so
first part is what I've just shown you
you know the return of patrimonial of
your wealth based society in Europe and
Japan where you know wealth income ratio
seemed to be returning to very high
levels in those low growth societies so
what characterizes Europe and Japan is
that you know in terms of productivity
growth is not very different from the US
but the population growth is a lot area
in the US so in in Japan or in many
European countries there's really no
population growth anymore and you know
the intuition is that in a slow growth
society wealth accumulated in the past
can naturally become very important you
know in the extreme case of a zero
growth society if you keep saving and
investing ten percent each year you know
the quantity of words is going to go to
infinity so you know at some point when
we have many flaws a per individual you
know probably the extra buildings and
the extra capital will not be very
useful and the rental price and the rent
for this extra floors will fall to zero
and people will stop saving now as long
as you have some positive growth this
will not happen so as long as you have
some positive population growth of
positive equity growth even if you keep
saying you know the quantity of capital
expressed in years of income of output
will not go to infinity but it can go to
very high levels you know when you with
a lower with a lower grocery and you
know this can be formalized with this
formula as divided by G where s is the
saving rate and G's of growth right but
you know the basic intuition is simply
in
now the second point that I would like
to make is really about the future of
West concentration once in equality if
you wish because as I was saying your
the fact that we returned to a
patrimonial
society you know if you have equal
access to wealth or you know not to
unequal access to wealth you know this
is not a program per se now the problem
is that wealth inequality is always a
lot larger and income inequality you
know I cannot show you the graph but
typically the share of national ways
going to the top 10% you know can be you
know ninety percent in three World War
one European societies and today it's
above seventy percent in the u.s.
whereas for income we've seen that you
it has gone from 30 to 50 percent in the
u.s. so it's forwards it's always more
extreme levels of inequalities and for
income and one of the determinants of
long-run wealth concentration is this
gap F F minus G where air is the rate of
return and G is the growth rate and let
me make clear that you know sometime
people are surprised when when you know
I say that and G R can be bigger than G
forever so you know it's very important
to understand that there is absolutely
no paradox yeah and that you know in
fact the simplest way to see that is to
go back through time and you know in
traditional agrarian societies it was
really obvious to everybody that our was
bigger than G and you know people when
we are not saying it this way but you
know the growth rate was zero
there was no population growth there was
no productivity growth or less than 0.1
percent per year and of course the rate
of return to capital was not zero you
know the rate of return to land for
instant was typically four five percent
per year you know it's obvious if you
take any novel by genestein or whether
that you if you want 1,000 pounds of
annual income you need a capital of
20,000 pounds and it's obvious that you
know general steam doesn't even need to
say you know it's a 5% return you know
she goes from 1,000 pounds in annual
income
thousand pounds in capital all the time
and everybody understands you know you
don't even need to explain it it is so
abuse and and and and in a way our
videos and she was a very foundation of
society because this is what makes it
possible for a group of landowners of
owners of whatever has said there was to
own to live off their property and not
to bother to care about their own
survival and devote the time to other
activities you know scientific literary
politics war whatever and now
the Industrial Revolution as changes a
little bit but not as much as what might
believe because the growth rate was
increased from 0% to 11.5% you know in
the 19th century the growth rate of GDP
in European countries and in industrial
nations you know is typically 11.5
percent per year which is a lot more
than zero percent you know this means
that in the space of a generation 30
years you have a you know 30 to 50
percent increase in output which is a
huge renewal of society and industrial
activity but this is not enough you know
11.5 percent to counteract the fact that
the rate of return was typically four
five percent or in fact the rate of
return even increased with new form of
industrial capital investment and you
know can be six seven percent for
typically on the stock market in the
long run for more risky assets so the
gap with the growth rate you know was
not really reduced and it isn't me you
know in the 20th century due to number
of very unusual events that this
inequality between R and G was reversed
so what were those unusual events you
know somewhere dramatic some were less
dramatic so the dramatic part is of
course what were one the Great
Depression World War two which reduced
the you know net of tax net of shark net
of destruction private rate of return to
very low level between 1914 and 1945 you
know the wealth of the past in Europe
and Japan was just destroyed and also
the post-war growth rate where unusual
large because of the reconstruction and
the recovery after the growth so you
have you know four five thousand growth
right particularly in Europe and Japan
but also to a lesser extent in the u.s.
the odds are not positive part of the
story about 20th century growth is that
you have unusually large population
growth which is a very important part of
total growth of GDP and which also acts
in the direction of making wealth
accumulated in the past less important
relative to new saving you know in a
country where everybody has 10 children
you know you should not come too much on
inheritance but now if you take the
opposite case where you know you have a
population decline no tax the extreme
case of a country that is about to
disappear in the last generation in
Germany around 2070 and then this is the
last generation of Germans you know they
will inherit all the words that was
accumulated by the previous century so
you know the inheritance flow as
compared to GDP can be you know
absolutely enormous I mean this is an
extreme case but if we look in between
what we are gonna have you know right
now you know in Germany actually in
China or in Japan or in Italy the size
of the generations that are born right
now are 30% smaller and the size of the
generation of the parents and you know
this is really a very unusual event in
history and this can push you know the
importance of inheritance you know even
further even more can become even
stronger than what we had in the 19th
century because you know if you have any
one children in each family basically
you inherit on both sides or on the
other side if both parents are cool and
you know the relative importance of
inherited wealth relative to new output
and new income and new saving can become
really now let me mention you know I
think when you know some people you know
like to say ok but your future is going
to be different because we are going to
have a lot of innovation a lot of growth
and you know growth will be ours and
then what you believe it you know it
could be that growth is going to be a
year because we always start to have a
lot of children and make a lot of
invention at the most faster rate and in
the past but you know I think it will be
quite you know risky to wait for this
incredible coincidence to happen you
know it will really take an incredible
coincidence for the growth rate to rise
to the level of the rate of return it's
really important to realize that there's
no natural force that pushes in this
direction you know these two notions are
determined by completely different
forces or largely different forces and
they have no reason to coincide
naturally no model of any thought you
have this prediction and certain is as
nice to recall evidence going in this
direction and I think the study of
history is important because I think we
should not be too naive about what you
know suddenly the huge potential for
growth in the future
for instance you know I know some people
in some reviews that I would not cite by
name you know telling me you know we
don't care about three World War one
Europe and you know the experience of
these countries because these were
agrarian societies with you know little
so you know I think the study of
actually the Belle poque period and you
know pre-world War one capitalism is
actually quite interesting because it
has nothing to do with you know an
agrarian society 1900 is the time where
you know we invent the automobile the
electricity is radio transatlantic steam
you know so this is less important and
Facebook of course but you are still
this is these are important innovations
and and in spite of all this very
important innovation you know the growth
rate of productivity was 11.5 percent
per year which is already very fast you
had at the level of a generation but
which was not enough to counteract this
from you know concentration of wealth
coming from from
you know from this our videos engine so
you know I think it would be really a
mistake just to believe that you know as
a miracle you know growth rates are
going to increase the to raise the level
of the rate of future you know maybe one
day we discover a planet where people
have so many children and make so many
inventions that the growth rate manages
to to reach to the rate of which one
naturally but you know in the meantime I
think it's it's more you know it's
matter to make other plans and to think
of other institution that could solve
the problem without this opinion so you
know the ideal way will be I believe you
know not to reduce you know the naive
way to solve the problem will be you
know if ours equal to 5 percent and G is
equal to one percent you know you just
tax 80 percent return to capital and you
bring him down to one person now if you
do that maybe the growth rate is going
to go to zero percent so this is not
very smart what I am proposing in the
book is bit more subtle than this this
is really the idea of a progressive tax
on net wealth so that in fact for you
know most of the populations that are
trying to enter into wealth accumulation
the tax will be zero or very small and
the tax rate will become I only for you
know very large level of wealth
concentration so the objective is to is
certainly not to reduce the quantity of
wealth or to reduce the average return
to capital but rather to make to
increase wealth mobility and to make the
distribution of wealth more democratic
so you know if you take for instance
right now in the US and in most European
countries you do have well-stacked you
have a take the form of the property tax
you know the tax on real estate property
the difference is that it is
proportional and not progressive and the
other important difference is that it
doesn't take into account financial
assets and financial debt so the
difference you know if I could rewrite
the US tax code directly in this room
tonight you know I will take the tax
revenue from the property tax
I will not increase these tax revenues
or promise not to increase the capital
tax per se but I will transform it in
progressive tax on net worth so for
instance you know if you have family
that has an apartment or house of
$500,000 but they have a mod gauge of
four hundred ninety thousand dollars you
know their net wealth is only $10,000 so
with the progressive tax on net wealth
they will pay no tax so in effect we
will reduce the property tax for you
know the bottom 90% of the population
but Zed for people you know who have
millions or billions in financial assets
and you know and we now are paying very
small property tax as a fraction of the
assets because so property tax doesn't
take into account financial assets and
real estate property you know they will
pay they will pay more tax now what kind
of tax rate should we have you know from
from the data we have at our disposal
you know this is not perfect data you
know this is data coming from the Forbes
wealth ranking let me say right away
that this is not a data source that's
particularly reliable but you know we
live at a time where people buy
magazines to have information on wells
because they don't find it you know
official publication statistics and
maybe when they find it but anyway what
we have is that you take a fixed
fraction of the world population the
wealth over you know since 1997 which is
when father started to publish the
ranking has increased at a real rate of
6 to 7% per year which is three times as
fast as a verage population in the world
average wealth for the world population
so even taking into account the growth
of China and the convergence that goes
with it you know the top of the world
distribution of wealth is rising 3 times
as fast as the size of the world economy
so you know the kind of you know it's
it's difficult to say that you is that
you know 1 or 2 percent tax rate would
kill this
this group of people you know apparently
you know right now they are increasing
you know at six seven percent per year
you know we find the same effect of
having very large rate of return for a
large Wells portfolio when I use much
higher quality data coming from
university endowments in the United
States so so this is a real annual rate
of return of so you have about 850
University in the US with capital on
demand so at least you know we have a
very precise financial statement on what
they do with their money so this is a
good thing you know we don't know that
with the fourth people list so you know
we can analyze and you what you get is
that with first the returns are I you
know if you have $100,000 and you go to
your banker and you will not have this
kind of return so clearly we have much
bigger return and the returns TP Rises
with the size of the young domain so you
know as long as it's only with
University and we believe that our third
is doing lots of useful things with the
manner and that's fine if it's for the
entire world population distribution of
wealth that you have this kind of
processes but I'm surely quite
destabilizing is is it possible to have
sort of fiscal response to this let me
conclude you know just by saying that
you know the study of history led me to
be you know reasonably optimistic in the
sense that you know the history of
taxation is full of surprise you know
and and you know so many people right
now you know are saying okay the
progressive well stacks would never
happen but you know many people in 1900
1910 were saying that the progressive
income tax would never happen and you
know in particular in this country in
the United States now many people in
1900 1910 we are pointing out quite
rightly that the constitution of this
country made it impossible for an income
tax at the federal level and you know
then the Constitution was an amendment
in the end the United States became the
country that invented steeply
progressive taxation of income partly
because the country did not want to
resemble to class freedom Europe in
terms of inequality and at that time you
know this can seem sort of strange today
but you have this you know having Fisher
president of the American Economic
Association making his big speech in
1919 and explaining you know my fellow
American economy is the biggest threat
to the American economy is that the
distribution of wealth is getting as
inequality in Europe and you know this
is an undemocratic distribution of
wealth that threatens our ideal and the
working of our economy and the world's
mobility that we need so you know the
political process in this country did
respond at that time and you know it
could respond in the future you know
this is the same with the tax rate and
inheritance you know with the tax rate
top tax rate on top inheritance were
also invented you know in the u.s. in
the UK it is true that in France and
Germany the destructions due to the did
a lot of the redistribution without the
tax system so I guess that's part of the
explanation but I think it's deeper than
that it's also that there was an
attachment to equality in the US and and
to try to avoid the kind of extreme
concentration of wealth that
characterized all Europe prior to World
War one that was very strong then just
from the anecdote you know it's
interesting to see that the only time
were Germany has a 90 percent top tax
rate is in 1946 1948 which is when the
tax policy of Germany is set by the
Americans and by the Allied Control
Council and you know this is the same
force inheritance tax and this is the
same in Japan the only time in Japan
where you have a 90 percent top tax rate
is in 1946 1948 and you know this was
not to punish Germans or the Japanese
because the US we are doing the same at
all so this was just part of the
civilization packages that
we're drinking you know together with
the democratic institutions you need
fiscal institution that prevent
democracy to become a plutocracy and and
that was a very strong you know us
believes that we must limit extreme
inequality
you know inequality is fine as long as
it is reasonable and in the common
interests you know when it becomes
extreme these threatens our democratic
institutions so you know things can
change you know faster than we can but
we sometimes think and and you know I'm
not terribly impressed by those we know
exactly what can or cannot happen in the
coming decades so let me say first and
it's a true honor to participate in this
panel as a political reporter I think I
can say that Tomas has done more as an
economist to change the political debate
then virtually anyone else that I can
think of he and his work with Emmanuel
Saez
they have put inequality on the map as
an issue and their findings about the
trends of in pre-tax income especially
at the very high level using in income
tax data has forced this issue to the
forefront and now with this book I think
we are going to see the issue of wealth
inequality gaining real steam and you
got people are actually going to have
discussions in which they talk about rvg
and all kinds of other arcane aspects as
a cynic I would say looking at this the
smartest investment strategy looking at
the size of this crowd and apparently
the clouds that he has been drawing all
over these coasts is you should invest
in graduate schools of economics
I this is going to be a growth area the
second piece of advice which is already
in his book is that the wisest strategy
if you're young and unmarried is to
marry someone rich might as well get in
on the wealth action while you can and I
the only downside on that is that the
saying if you marry for money you pay
for it the rest of your life so at any
rate that's it that's your choice I have
a series of basically questions as
opposed to commentary I'm not an
economist so I wouldn't pretend to be
sophisticated in this one is that you
say you're an optimist at the end and
you're optimistic about the possibility
of real change but there is a quality of
inevitability in this ratio of the
return on capital and the much lower
level of the rate of growth of GNP and
it is the only solution a at least we
journal tax and at better yet a global
tax on wealth is that the only way to
cut that off related to that would be is
it possible to and I know this has come
up with some of your previous
appearances to try to redistribute
capital as opposed to redistributing
income that developing some mechanisms
for finding ways to increase stockholder
investments on the part of employees
there's been talk of getting a birth
wealth grant in a sense the is that an
alternative way to do those through
those kind of tactics work the you you
also in the book you raise questions
about the effectiveness of traditional
tax and spending policies to correct
correct the trends that was
now of growing inequality and stacked
and wages for those in the middle and
bottom rungs
again that is lends to this pessimism
what's really striking is how this book
which you say is optimistic I would say
it's pessimistic but it appeals to
liberals and I wonder if there's
something about pessimism that liberals
like but I that's off the track
third you say you think that this keep
that taxation there's a history of
surprises in taxation where is the
political will going to come to initiate
a tax on wealth I'm not questioning its
legitimacy but where are you going to
find the constituencies that will
support something like that because at
the same time presumably the concept of
increased concentration of wealth is
resulting in a concentration of
political power insofar as money is a
form of political power and so the
pursuit I would assume there would be
opposition from those at the top to such
a proposal and if anything their
financial position their ability to
fight it as only is increasing and
certainly looks that way in the United
States when you just look at the failure
of the tax hedge fund income for example
or even considering raising the cap on
Social Security FICA taxes higher how I
don't want to go on too long with too
many questions but a couple more one is
out of this the recent surge in the
interest of robotics and the
substitution of technology for human
labor how does that fit into this
argument of yours and reinforce it in
effect because that would seem to be a
at an intensification of the shift of
ink of a shift of income to capital and
the two other things one is what about
human capital for example the ownership
of patents where you may not be able to
have a value at a sign to them and if
you're going to tax that how do you get
at that because that I think human
capital has become an increasingly
important part of the of capital per se
or the the a partnership in a law firm
or a business where it may be harder to
unlike what you were describing in the
book where you could get bank balances
and you can get a high degree of
transparency on physical or cash assets
it's harder to in terms of these less
transparent forms of capital and finally
can you is there a danger that if you
tax capital the owners of capital will
find ways to pass those taxes on to
consumers that presumably they're they
own capital that in many respects
produces goods for sale can they in a
way just impose that burden on the same
people you're trying to help out and
I'll leave it there
I was invited to speak at as a historian
not not as an economist I entitled my
comments in a very flippant way how
Piketty 'the capital in the twenty-first
century piques the historians interest
historians as you know are very
interested in change over time and in
scrutinizing the sources for their
validity for the purpose for which
they're intended and then very very
interested in causes and consequences
and in all of that there was if you want
categories so my work is is remarkable
in the first sense it's extraordinarily
cordial in its opening its welcome to
his historians not just is he interested
in a very long period far longer than
historians normally take on was there
French historians but he's also worked
enormously as he demonstrated with Anna
keep which was exactly what was called
for to develop this database which he
could have just left there had students
work with but then arduously also put
together in a book which in some ways is
rhubarb ative in its organization at
least for an historian because he's
working around its categories but which
is also very very readable and very
aware of the reader he is also very
attuned to sources that historians use
not just these tax income tax other
economic data but also in his effort to
use literary sources novels novels to
understand the political economy we'll
come back to that in a very very nice
way but above all he also makes a point
which is a very powerful method of law
point to integrate social sciences
humanities history with economics
political science sociology and taking
history as the most important source of
experience and of knowledge so that is
an extraordinarily generous overture to
the historian now beyond that he also is
very interested in historicizing himself
and economic theory as well and that is
something which just is so welcome and
for that I think we have so many people
here today that he's somebody who's
saying explicitly in the book that he
himself is coming out of a certain time
and therefore can look at the past with
a certain sort of subject position which
is then supported by historical research
that is he is it's a post 68 he's coming
in to his work with a very different
vision from that let's say I had which
was being born in that the great
miraculous curve of post-war where we
were always riding with a sense of the
future of prosperity using credit cards
because that was possible as part of you
know couldn't decide whether it was
savings or credit because you're always
getting some sort of increase in salary
in that period and rising and with this
very large demographic cohort he's very
insistent then that in some ways that we
the economists should be conscious of
where they were situated historically
and that since he takes on Kuznets who
was part in some ways in the great
American economic miracle and therefore
was very inclined to see as a law
regularity of economic theory that
incomes would tend to converge being
part if you wanted mid mid twentieth
century in some sense we can go on from
how he wants to historic economists and
say probably the rat was radical thing
short of the tax on wealth that could
come out at least today is that
make obligatory history of economic
thought in all our economics classes and
for our economics majors it's a disaster
the shallow level of historical
knowledge and that many ways I think is
why we've been kept for more than 20
years from having any notion that what
we were seeing was historically specific
to this period that there was a another
period earlier and that somehow the
period of the last 30 years connects to
a prior period that before 1910 and what
makes them this book remarkable as it
says so firmly that that is not indeed
the story and we have to ask well why in
the United States when there's been such
dramatic changes in the last 30 years
very self-evidently without the long
economic series we've been so deeply
unable to see these transformations
through the eyes of our economists this
openness about the his work and who he
is then it makes it sort of easy to easy
but to sort of describe where he comes
from
Immanuel Saddam already started - she's
historians sociologists I would try just
another step to make him that's a little
more recognizable that's to me or
perhaps and sort of a transatlantic
framework he's an economist trained in
the US and I would say he's neoclassical
training which comes through and that is
certainly a subject of a considerable
amount of criticism from neo-keynesian
isms and Marxist but at the same time
very deeply and you could say they sort
of sit next to each other in a somewhat
uneasy way he is comes out of a
durkheimian tradition which we could see
and let's see simians work on salary or
huh box on the evolution of consumption
which deeply believes that society
exists and solidarity exists even before
the market and so the big question that
when is faced with is how does the
market how does capital make what people
diverge as
at other times converge and this is I
think very very crucial to his whole
undertaking finally okay just as for the
historians historic and historians point
of view that he is very very interested
to say in the study of inequality okay
so the longer a and figuring out
inequality which is not necessarily you
know a problem that is given indeed if
you look at an Engram nineteen let's say
1942 2008 the word inequality and
standard of living they're often used
together on equality sanity of living
its begin to droop around 1978 and they
lie flat whereas human rights goes
leaping up in the early 1980s I think
now if we extend the Engram to 2015 the
publication of this book is going to
lead the word inequality to surge in a
very very radical way but it's very
rangy so he's bringing back in as a
historian and as an economist the
problem of inequality which have been
very much abandoned in the 1980s the the
for me probably one of the most
surprising problems that his narrative
an asteroid of which he brings back
which is also if you want to break with
postmodern historiography which is
tended to break up time and have whole
sets of other questions is that that we
had thought in some ways that we were
you know in a week give a sense of
history even was tinged by Marxism is he
either things are going to become more
and more dynamic and more and more
catastrophic more and more dynamic and
then you get to globalization phase
which was always treated by historians
journalists as creating a kind of global
wealth and probably the most surprising
element for it for me as an historian
was to see that there was a period that
goes from 1910 to 1919 70s
there was this dis accumulation and that
point I wanted to come back to it so it
the traditional history of the 20th
century late 19th 20th century is you
get you know everything collapses in the
1920s and 1930s one that's 30 crisis
years and then lessons are learned and
we begin to all be Keynesian Zand for 30
years things go very very well and that
is not the story he's telling it's
actually a much more and I think more
dismal story now clearly this way he
uses history has to raise questions for
in my case for the historian one is the
nature of capital I mean one way that
historians have tried to work is by
giving a less economic notion of capital
as something substantially more
complicated and richer and not only
economic so that capital becomes
capitalism in a lot of our work these
were interested in Congress and
distribution and social status and class
and so on it becomes a way of organizing
about regulating in that sense I think a
lot of historians have learned or at
least been if you want influenced some
by the regulation of school that is
Fordism mean something it's a whole way
of organizing capital feudalism means
something and and and state capitalism
means something and so that becomes a
question for me you know that's how your
notion of capital isn't it too
restricted to wealth understood as
economic assets second the problem in
equality can we understand inequality in
the way that you set it up as income I
was a classical locus classicness of
comparing any meited States and Europe
but like very stone Bart why is there no
socialism in America
guess it's not books about 1902 sort of
confusing this year maybe 1905 in any
case he's saying that actually that
inequalities far greater in the United
States economically but all these
workers they think they're as good as
anybody else and in their dress they
could sort you know managers and workers
it's something
his imagination and then he makes a
point though there's no feudalism and
traces it back to that so I'm wondering
exactly how economic wealth translates
into other problems that is the problems
that you know perceptions of inequality
that would lead people then to support a
tax on wealth not unrelated to that is
how inequality then gets transformed
into other kinds of difference in
inequality a couple of times you cite
Balzac and pare goryeo and the idea that
he has 50,000 he has to settle fifty
thousand an observer leave on his
daughters well that's turning them into
shadow into cattle and so it raises all
kinds of questions about not just
oligarchy but patrimonial capitalism
also about patriarchy and I think that's
actually some something you might I'm
sure can consider I have you know
questions about that period which is
both so horrible and then so glorious
that is nineteen fifteen to nineteen
seventy how we put it together when one
seems to be the negation of you know I
kind of normal capitalism in its taking
to its most imperialistic rapacious
forms plunder and the other is the most
glorious moment where there seems to be
a welfare state and finally I guess I
have you know questions about the the
mid year in which these experiments
which are basically transatlantic are
taking place that is a media with
enormous social invention over the
previous century trade unions all kinds
of mechanisms and cooperative social
solidarity the Soviet Union if you want
as an experimentation against oligarchic
wealth and how you connect that how you
place that form and last but not least
about this progressive global tax on
wealth
that sounds so French in some ways that
is a kind of ante you know kind of
populism that comes out seeing the
pyramid so clearly on Paris it's like
bored you you look up and you see this
sort of you know the Occupy or the you
know the 40 wealthy families which
Americans classically do not see or as
you pointed out see as merit
meritocratic you know you're an athlete
or if you're Steve Jobs there's a kind
of folk hero quality to them which is
ideological as well as I think you're
suggesting is it's also driven about
know some notions of allocating income
so why a wealth tax which could only
just get people very furious why not
you other kinds of human agency minimum
wage that would make people recruit more
democratic well combative
why not estate taxes to prevent
dynasties why not promote unions or
solidarities of all sorts cooperatives
why not
Corp tax corporate profits and personal
fat capital gains including dividends
okay why not set up big banking
cooperatives that was an idea that SAS
emo and others had and seems like would
be a good substitute for the current
banks changing patent law so I'm in
sometimes I'm suggesting perhaps that
some of the there are some limits in
your solutions maybe suggesting some of
the limits and the way the problem
inequality is posed as as as wealth as
in a certain kind of capital all this is
to say all these questions are provoked
by this generous incredibly erudite
difficult work and it first and foremost
made me want to go back and start
rereading all the classics setting up
study groups like we had in the 60s and
I think try to imagine how you know if I
were writing to set 2050 this work this
work represents in terms of your total
corpus of undertakings
all right so I'll try to keep it short
and I'll try to do my discipline some
justice and so I mean you just think
that I haven't I don't think there's
been a book that sort of come out of
economics that has this much influence
since free to choose but Milton Friedman
which then you know also came out of a
particular political position and then
defended it with the best economics of
its day with the best writing of his day
and I don't think there's been another
book sort of of this of that sort of
magnitude coming out of economics since
that and so that's sort of really great
and and and and so that's you know some
testimony because that book sort of set
the agenda for like lots of how people
saw economics even well after economics
had moved on it still was like the the
ideological veneer that economics had in
public and so now I hope that like
undergrads are people that see economics
now night maybe think not just Milton
Friedman but also add tomato to the sort
of what they sort of proceeded so but
but let me let me then sort of push back
a bit and and like ask a few questions
so here's what I here's what I worry I
worry there's going to be the
domesticated Paquette e ISM there's
going to be a Paquette e ISM that is a
bastard Paquette e ISM as some of my
friends have called it and that that
there's essentially going to be this way
in which this argument this like rich
incredible 700 page book gets boiled
down by a set of like technocratic wants
and economists into a story about about
technology about the elasticity of
substitution about about like these
inexorable forces making capital and
labor more more substitutable over time
and and that being like these sort of
technical or market market forces sort
of being what's driving the accumulation
of capital and also explaining why are
isn't falling and so this then will sort
of come back and I think I'd be curious
is because tomorrow I think the tension
in the book is that he come
back to neoclassical forces moves into
institutions and politics and say this
says that the more important and then
comes back and says well but the
marginal product is still what's
determining the the price and I sort of
want to yeah pushed and asked him to
commit to one of these one of these two
stories so so for example and because I
think that the marginal product story is
what economists are going to take away
from it and are what going to what
they're going to work for and I want to
see if there's a way to instead use this
book as a way to sort of change how
economists think about what determines
the prices of a capital and in in the in
sort of our canonical models for how we
how we do it
so because let me give you an another
story from another side of economics
right from like a like a Keynesian point
of view so so for freaky so for Keynes
right there's this moment that like the
the the rate of return on capital is set
not so much by supply and demand but
it's actually a project of social norms
and and and expectations about demand
and and sort of this sort of set of just
priors that people have that aren't
coming out of like predicting you know
they're choosing how much to buy of
something making some sort of very wild
guess about what they think it's going
to pay off in the future and and so you
know there's like there's a quote from
Keynes I wrote down but the most stable
and least easily shifted element in our
contemporary economy has been and may
prove to be in the future the minimum
rate of interest acceptable to the
generality of wealth owners and then he
footnotes John Bull the figurative
Englishman can stand many many things
but 2% he cannot stand and and so that
that this idea that there's in fact like
a social norm anchoring the rate of
return on capital and you know
economists we're now very comfortable at
the idea that social norms set wages but
where we're still working to the idea
that social norms can actually set the
rate of return on capital I sort of
would like then once you then take the
return rate of return on capital out of
the purely market determined thing and
then put it into the realm where it has
to be determined by institutions by
bargaining then that is
you know that makes other parts that
actually the book more integrates them
more so for example there's really great
footnotes and sections on corporate
governance and like the gap between
market and book values of capital so
what's going on here and one of the
really sort of great interpretations in
the book is that there's this there's
two kinds of ownership right there's the
cash flow rights to an asset and then
there's the control rights to an asset
and that one of the reasons that in in
in Germany you know in Germany you have
that the actual market value of stuff is
much less than the book value of the
underlying assets and that's because
it's a stakeholder model of corporate
governance where you have lots of lots
of people that are not just the
shareholders having substantial rights
over how that firm is run and so you
know one of the things that points is
that that's like a totally different set
of margins
besides the wealth tax that you can
think of for altering what capital does
it's altering the distribution of
control rights it's saying who has a say
in the running of a firm who's got a say
in the running of an apartment building
that that then lets us sort of think not
just about capital as the thing that's
written down in the balance sheets but
over who's got what rights to do with
what's written down in the balance sheet
and so that's sort of what I like and
then it's also when you have that that
view but this interest rate being set
institutionally it makes a bunch of
labor market reforms look more feasible
because I think if you're in this world
there's just the elasticity of
substitution then you basically think
well if you increase the minimum wage
you're just going to substitute it with
robots and so it's not going to do very
much work but if you instead have this
world that like the rate of return is
determined by a much more sticky
institutional process it gives you a
scope for raising wages that isn't just
going to translate into into lower
employment so that's sort of one set of
things that I would like to take a stand
on these good it's interesting because
this is a debate that's been happening
in labor economics for 15 years is like
is that institutions or technology
there's been determining whether or not
the gap between college-educated workers
and non college-educated workers has
been growing and so I just like to take
that into the realm of capital okay so
let me then switch and
- like the economic historian part of
this very quickly and just say so why do
we care that the data goes before World
War two I mean why isn't it enough to
just document that it's increased over
the last 35 years and I think and I
think the book serve shows this is that
one of the things one of the reasons we
do economic history those few precious
of us that do it is that is that we feel
like you know when you study these
things in the past you get a sense of
the library of options that's available
to you and just how diverse like
capitalism's can look and so the and
then and then it gives you them ideas
for looking at other things so for
example the analogies about how the
marriage market works in in the late
19th century tells something well is
that how the marriage markets gonna work
when you know wealth inequality goes it
goes up now so so that's that's I think
it's really great that you learn stuff
by you know you've when you run the data
set back you sort of then can sort of
see what are other things about that
time period that looked like the time
period where the data looks like that
like looked like that again and and so
but but then what that also tells us is
that what does the late 19th century
look like in terms of its in terms of
instance of its institutions and if it
looks like in the north and in the south
it looks like an incredible period of
conflict actually that like the the US
military is deployed more times on
foreign on US soil in the late 19th
century to brake strikes then until you
know then ever in the period of time the
the south is sort of run by you know
essentially a it's essentially an
apartheid state and so that that that is
sort of what the costs of inequality
look like is just open warfare and one
dimension and if you don't get it if it
doesn't go up into open warfare means
that you're spending a lot of resources
trying to prevent that open warfare and
so that's just wasteful even if you
don't see it so the idea that like if
inequality then winds up with a whole
bunch of speed people spending a lot of
money on gated enclaves and security
guards that that's like a social cost of
this that's gonna that we're going to
going to sort of
um so let me sort of also say one last
thing that that that but I think the
analogy also breaks down in that just we
right now live in a society that's way
more marketized than anything in the
19th century there's much more stuff
that just you can buy and sell on
markets and that actually I think
interacts with inequality in a much more
menacing way in that like when you can
put more stuff on the market that means
what you can get with a dollar is a lot
higher so in a way that the less
commodified society has a much like
wealth doesn't get you as much as a
society that puts way more on the market
and so there's this interaction between
like commodification and just you know
saying that the market is the best
institution for allocating stuff and
then which if you then have that
together with a huge inequality of
wealth it just makes it that much that
much worse so I think you can think of
one of the antidotes to inequality is
actually taking stuff off the market and
allocating it according it to different
principles ok so I was going to say
something about political constituencies
and actually offer that like immigration
is partly maybe our one one great hope
for both the economic reasons of raising
the growth rate that like an for some of
the studies development also that you
know when you think of the library of
options for getting poor people out of
their circumstances opening the borders
sort of one of the best things you can
do and and then I think in terms of
raising the demographic growth rate
raising the overall growth rate in the
core countries that's certainly
something that's kept the u.s. equal
historically but then I also want to
suggest that politically these are the
people that might actually be the the
that the young Restless people of the
developing world are sort of where the
political energy for redistribution at
the world level is going to come from
and that I think this was the case in
the 19th century was that basically a
lot of political movements in the u.s.
were born out of immigration and and so
I think that's that that sort of the the
that there's not just an economic sort
of payout reason to sort of think about
expanding immigration
as a totally equally politically
infeasible margin just like a global
wealth tax but is another sort of way to
to sort of encounter some of these
problems at least in the short run
okay so maybe tomorrow you could you
know pick some of the questions there
were too many questions by the panelists
for you to answer but one or two
questions that you want to answer so
that we can have time - yeah so you know
let me go very quickly you know thanks a
lot to the three of you for all those
comments you know I really agree with
pretty much everything you know I think
it's a you know in particular you know
all these different policy tools that
have been that you have been referring
to you know I think they are all
complimentary you know it's not we don't
have to choose between a minimum wage
and you know progressive well stacks you
know we don't have to choose between the
pattern flow and the union and about you
know so you know I think these are all
complementary they do different things
and and you know but you know the reason
why so maybe let me still say a few
words in you know indifference of
progressive taxation of words you know
the first the political questions that
ask you know what will be you know what
would be the constituency that would be
interested in that you know certainly
those who will pay more tax would not be
the main constituency but you know I
think you know the bottom 50% in the
u.s. own 2% of national wealth now they
don't vote that much but you know the
next 40 percent they own 22 percent of
national wealth and they've got a lot
more and and and for this ninety percent
of the population you know I think
finding a way to reduce their tax burden
and in particular the property tax and
you know I think many people have seen
you know in the in the recent crisis
that you know you have some people whose
property value is below the Ahmad range
and still this pays the same property
taxes as people who have no mortgage at
all and possibly they buy more property
tax and someone was lots of financial
assets
the smallest part of robots value so you
know it's a the old system of property
taxation that we have comes from the
19th century at a time where property
was real estate that was very rich in
financial assets and an immediate
financial debt and I think it's just not
adequate to the structure of wealth and
we have today and if we want to promote
broader access to wealth you know I
think there's a constituency of you know
lots of people who would like to become
owners and accurate wealth and we've you
know face difficulties so I think the
right way to to I think to defend this
politically will be to stress you know
all the people that will pay less tax
and that will you know be able to access
wealth rather than simply those who will
pay more so of course those who pay more
you know scream and say that this is too
much but you know if they are you know
rising three times as fast as the size
of the economy you know you cannot
pretend too much that you are about to
die or disappear you know so so but now
you know the best Wells grant you know
this is these are interesting ideas you
know is that will be like negative well
stacks for people who have zero wealth
so this is making the well stacks even
more progressive in a way I mean but
it's slightly different approach but
again this is complementary and you know
I am very I am very open about that you
know I'm not it's not that you know as
if I you know I know exactly the kind of
you know approach to making Wells more
in Poland and making you know increasing
wealth mobility certainly can be done
with you know large variety of option
yes let me pick one or two issues you
know migration can raise the growth rate
yes now I mean this has been the way for
for America to raise its growth rate and
you know you could have you know the
entire planet could move to America and
you know I think this is what US
universities would like to do with
academics you know but now the problem
is that if we all move to America then
we will
the same problem of our bigger than G to
solve in America so you know this is not
you know or unless we all have more
children when we are in America but you
know it's at the end of the day
migration you know it's very important
but that's not solving in the long run
our energy problem but this is buying
time and you know in America buying tank
and we can give you a lot of time so
this is a very important yeah you know I
I really I really don't believe you know
in the one sector one good and the Oh
classical model you know I don't think
this is a good description of any
economy and society I try in the book to
give justice to the multidimensionality
of capital and I try to show that the
history of land is not the story of real
estate is not the story of financial
assets is not the story of public debt
and you know when you sum up all these
pieces of assets different assets at
market values and you have a great stuff
of capital you know she's a very
abstract operation and and it can be
useful for some purposes but I you know
I of course don't believe that this
provides an adequate description of what
is capital you have different you know
social compromises for different types
of assets different type of negotiation
and and now I think Steve that it is
important the other is you know in the
economic debate you know to show that
your even if this very abstract
conditions of the one good economic
model are satisfied you know even with
the most perfect capital markets you
know full and perfect competition you
know we still have the problem of our
bigger than G we still have the problem
of extreme concentration of wealth and
you know I think this is an important
message because you know economists tend
to believe that you know perfect
competition can solve everything and
your perfect market can serve everything
so you know you know I started on
building the perfect market model even
if you know the conditions where we
where there you know that would not
solve the problem I mentioned I
mentioned you know let me yeah let me
stop there you know the rise of robots
you know this can contribute to make the
rate of return I but you know there are
also forces that that can play a big
role and you know international
competition to attract capital
investment and you know change in the
bargaining power of capital versus
unions versus labor you know is
important as well but yes the change in
the technology you know you don't need
to go all the way to a robot economy to
have a substantial change in the capital
share so just a little more possibility
to substitute capital and labor can be
very damaging I think for you know for
our social fabric so very small
departure from the standard economic
model you know can be can be really very
damaging in the long run anyway thanks
to all of three forces for the comments
and
so actually so now we have time for
questions you all here for that I'm sure
almost all of you are here for that we
we have a mic here and the best way to
you know I don't want to have to film
the question the best way would be to
you know go to the mic and ask questions
directly to Tama you can maybe either
stand up here and speak in the mic
so actually for the sake of saving a
little time maybe we're going to take
three questions at a time and then
tomorrow we'll answer three questions
and that would might make things it's
all faster
Thanks so about globalization Thomas it
seems to be pushing down wages at the
same time as its increasing the
profitability of capital
what about globalization is it
contributing to this inequality
hi um so as you may have been reading
Larry Summers and others who worry about
the so-called secular stagnation have
been in fact worried that are is really
low and that the long-run view of our is
that it's going to be depressed and this
is why the recovery has been so slow and
I was wondering whether you've thought
much about how your work on our being
greater than G and our being rather
elevated whether it speaks at all to
this debate that Larry summer to this
argument that Larry Summers and others
had made about secular stagnation I'm
curious what you might advise President
to do for the remainder of this term yes
globalization definitely contribute to
the evolutions I described and you know
falling wages at least for lower skill
groups in industrial countries and and
you know rising return to capital now
regarding the return to capital and the
some off point about you know the real
interest rate and public debt going to
zero or actually zero or negative you
know I think it's important to realize
that the rate of return to capital is so
much broader of concepts and just
interest rate and public debt so you
know when we see the top of the wealth
distribution when we see our our
university endowments you know rising at
8% or 7% per year
you know presumably they don't have
Treasury bonds in their portfolio so you
know looking at the interest rate and
Treasury bonds
is very interesting for a number of
purposes but you know this is not the
return to capital because public debt is
only one part of the assets that people
have and in fact it's not such a big
asset you know as compared to you know
equity on the stock market or real
estate and you know sophisticated
financial assets so I guess the right
way to look at the problem is to look at
the evolution of the capital shares in
GDP so the capital share measures all
the income that goes to capital so this
includes interest payment but it also
includes dividends corporate profits
rent rental income and and this is
certainly not funny so you know if the
problem that some of the scribe you know
whether the rate of return of capital
goes to zero you know the capital share
should go to zero and you know
apparently the capital share is not
going to zero at all you know it has
been rising in industrialized countries
you know over the past thirty years and
in fact across the world now what is
true though and where some of us is
partly right is that the rise in the
capital share has been less stronger
than the rise in the capital to income
ratio which means that the rate of
return indeed has declined somewhat but
it has declined less than the increase
in the quantity of capital so that the
capital share which is a product of the
two as actually increased but still it
is true that when you accumulate more
capital you know the rate of return as
to fall somewhat you know the question
is does it for more or less in
proportions and the rise in the quantity
and the evidence at least in the past
circles does it fell less than the
increase in the quantity now what's
going to happen in the future you know
what I think some of the very large
discrepancies that we observe in in
between interest rate and rate of return
have to do of course with our monetary
policy and what central banks have been
doing in the past few years is the
crisis and you know I think generally
speaking
probably we
you know we have been asking too much to
Central Bank's and Twitter to you know a
fiscal system you know so central bank's
you know they are very powerful because
you can create you know billions of
dollars and euros in one day and they
can lend it to whoever they want you
know the promise that sometimes they
don't know what they are doing you know
they they and so the tax system is more
complicated because you know before
reacting you need to write the tax law
you need to have it approved by
Parliament you need to have to write
your rules you know what your tax base
you need to write your tax right but at
least you know you sort of know in
principle who's going to pay what at the
end so we need both we need both central
banks and and tax system but in the
recent past and certainly to get out of
this financial crisis we've been putting
you know all the burden both you know in
the US and even more so in Europe we are
you know the only federal institution is
the European Central Bank and they are
doing what they can but you know you
cannot ask a central bank to do what the
government budget and a current tax
system could do and and this brings me
to President or rather you know I think
the most important issue for the future
of you know in France and and Europe is
really the integration political and
fiscal integration of the euro zone and
you know yeah you know a lot sort of
pretends that he's in favor of for
instance a common public debt with
Germany but in fact you know you would
like France to keep working its deficit
on its own so you know it's very easy
for Germany to say look this is not a
proposal you know and the Bundesbank
president you know with someone very
conservative and I certainly don't agree
with him all the time but it was very
easy for him to respond look you want to
come and credit cut and then keep doing
your shopping on your own you know this
does not this doesn't work so you know I
am trying to be more consistent in the
you know in your chapter in the book you
know I I say you know if you want to
have a proper regulation of you know
modern financial capitalism you
certainly want to have you know more
integration political integration so
overall the eurozone you need to have a
common public debt but then you need to
have also you know a common corporate
tax base but overall even more than that
you need to come
eurozone Parliament to vote the common
deficit and the current corporate tax
base you know you cannot work and I
think you know it's easy in France
always to blame to blame Germany for
being selfish but I think Germany is
much more advanced in its thinking of
federal political union in Europe and
then political parties in France goes
from the left and from the right and so
you know if you're going to do something
you know I'm not sure but we'll see
thank you for your presentation
professor I'm told the discussants a
very quick question of course it's not
your job to speculate about the future
but still I think it will be important
for you to expand if possible just on
what you mean what do you think are the
main implications of a rise in wealth
inequality professor Snyder just talked
about the social potential social cost
but I would like to see your view do you
think that at certain point of high
wealth inequality we could get some it
could come at the detriment of economic
growth or not or because in order to
take coordinated policy action we need
to be very clear about the goals and why
we should do something against it thank
you thank you for the amazing book and
as a as a PhD student in history it's a
it's very refreshing to actually see a
political economist who's engaging
history now the question I have is for
the panel in general and I'm still
slugging my way through the book and
there's this question applies to all of
you which is I don't expect academics or
any of you to actually be prescriptive
in your in your way of engaging in this
dialogue about inequality but what I
think is I notice throughout all the
comments and as well as professor
piketty's book two is this reluctance to
actually just say we know what the
problem is we've seen what the problem
is and this is what we think should
happen it said what I keep saying is
this well if we do this then those who
own the means of wealth might actually
turn on us and do that or if we try this
possibility they might do this is there
I'm wondering
if there's a responsibility to actually
just come out and say listen 90% of
people are in this position 10% of
people own this much and we need to
reverse this trend and something needs
to be done and this is it it may not be
the one single solution but maybe
somebody needs to get up seize the
capital and do something for those who
are at the bottom so to many sort of
like putting it under the table or
whether this will work we actually know
to some extent watching the history
looking at the history we know at
moments what the taxes were hide help
redistribute wealth how it helps some
classes of people and we know at some
moments who eventually use their own
political power to take back that wealth
right I'm thinking of Mellon being the
the secretary or at one point you know
before the Great Depression so my
question is can we if you're gonna
propose an 80% tell solution in terms of
taxing wealth can we just say oh maybe
can we just say actually I think that's
what needs to be done rather than
actually I'm kind of pessimistic but I'm
gonna propose it anyway so more
resolution to some extent is what I'm
asking are you willing to provide a
resolution that does not dance around
the question my question touches on the
first question that was asked and as
well as something that serration I just
said earlier which was about the the
relationship of inequality to conflict
to social instability you know which
which we saw so much of in the 19th
century I've been out of school for a
while so it'll be difficult for me to
footnote this this this statement but I
I remember reading in it of a in a in a
development economics class that they
could that they that the conflict as a
result of inequality is much more likely
when income and wealth inequality are
correlated or area are correlated with
horizontal inequalities between
inequalities and that already exists
among social groups and inequalities
that exist between between described
identity
and I was wondering whether you found
that in your work how that bears upon
your work and how that bears upon our
our future
okay so um I just I'm gonna come the I'm
the two questions I think I mean I'm not
saying that there's going to be conflict
and I'm thinking but if we don't have
conflict that's going to be because
we're spending a ton of resources
avoiding and those resources are you
allowed to go it could be hiring a bunch
of economists to like say that we'll be
spending a it'll be it'll be a social
calm and I'm the sort of last point
about race and group inequalities I
think it's actually I didn't say this
but it I actually think there's an
interesting case of our reparations sort
of dovetailing with the global wealth
tax that you know that in some ways like
reparations are way too like undue
historical injustice by you know which
have perpetuated probably through the
accumulation of wealth and so that rep
rate a way to I don't know you know
obviously the reparations debate has
been had in the u.s. for a long time but
it keeps coming up with slavery in the
Caribbean it keeps coming up in the US
and that this might be the language that
we need to put forward something on on a
wealth tax because that's kind of you
know one of the ways you could fund this
kind of pull over man
on the question about standing up and
saying what you think ought to be done I
I would plead on my own part that I'm an
equivocal guy but I don't think you
could say that about Tomas and say as
they are very explicit than what they
and he wants a well tax and he's talked
about much higher tax rates on income
quite specifically I don't think in the
case of the principal speaker here
there's been an a pussyfooting around I
I put C foot around but that's that's
different just just very quickly I try
to to text and you know of spookin and
generally make in my writing in fact you
know I'm probably taking position much
mores and then you know in a much more
in certain to tell you the truth about
you know just as everyone of us about
what exactly should be done and I don't
you know I understand also knows the
arguments and counter-arguments for each
such of such policy so you know I guess
you know I'm trying to take position but
usually I get most comments saying that
I take too much position so I know I
should go
so let's go you know that completed
inequality I think I'd like you answer
without you know I think you know
whether you have conflict you know even
when you don't see it and sometimes even
when you don't see it yes you spend a
lot of resources you know whether it's a
persuasion apparatus or repression
apparatus you know both are very
consuming in terms of resources so I
I haven't read the book so perhaps I'm
saying something that you discuss in the
book but it seems to me today there has
not been a sufficient attention to the
relationship between robot ization and
rising unemployment and how that
contributes to greater inequality so I
have a question I would be interested in
knowing whether you think regulation of
Finance and how you know finance and
financial innovation in the way
different intermediaries have behaved
prior to and during the crisis may
relate to an increase in the gap between
R and G and how you think you know how
relate to do you think regulation of
Finance and the preventing of further
crises might be related to you know
fighting inequality this is a question
for the whole panel I guess I would like
to know what do you expect in in the
American political debate in terms of
inequality you've all been saying like
this is a great work and there is a lot
of writing in the press about your book
mr. piketty okay that's fantastic but
inequality is already a sexy word for
the coming midterm we we can hear it a
lot already from both parties in the
u.s. so it's not new of course and so
what do you expect what do you expect
from this writing what do you expect
from other academics research in a few
months just in the few coming months
maybe thank you
okay so rising robot ization are
definitely can you know raise inequality
both because it reduces you know the
potential a wage of low skilled and
middle skilled workers and also because
it raises the return to capital
potentially or at least prevent the
return from capital to fall as much as
it should otherwise when you accumulate
more more capital financial deregulation
also adds the sort of Joel impact both
on you know labor earnings inequality
with contributed to the rise of very top
labor compensation in the financial
sector and I think also you know another
effect that I'm describing in the book
is that it has the finance the
development of very complex financial
products has probably increased
inequality in access to good return to
capital so you know when you have a
small portfolio and you know you when
and read those in dollars or a few
hundred thousand dollars you know you
don't have access to very sophisticated
financial instruments and you get very
low returns and very large portfolios
you know can have access to much more
sophisticated financial products and so
instead in principle you know the in the
perfect capital market model financial
intermediation supposed to bring those
the same return to everyone and the best
possible return a view and if anything
it has probably increase the inequality
in access to good returns and so you
know this has been a very very important
you know political action for the
midterm election you know as far as I am
concerned I am I'm more concerned with
European parliamentary elections and
with the midterm US election and I
invite you to sign a manifesto for
closer
political union of the eurozone that you
know I have returned with a number of
people which has been translated in
German English Netherlands Spanish
Italian and published in the main
newspaper of Europe and and you know
that's my little way of doing political
action and but you know I'm sure that
others and that
done with telus of those I think the
issue of inequality is very complex and
at the end there's been actually some
withdrawing from the the issue on the
part of Democrats and Obama it's let me
for my own I think that it's a problem
issue if you raise it as a transfer of
income because most middle-class people
hear a word like inequality and we've
got to do something about it indicating
that Democrats want to transfer income
from middle-class people to poor people
if it's put in the context that there
are very rich people getting away like
bandits collecting money that they don't
deserve at your expense then it's a
winning issue but at the Democratic
Party as it's currently constructed is
reluctant to take that kind of
aggressive posture so I think to some
extent the issue is going to be more
muted in this political campaign then
perhaps it ought to be one of the light
motifs of the book recurred also the
presentation was the the role of the
university the elite university as a
kind of condenser of of inequalities and
I think we've done very little at
Columbia to pull together our thinking
about inequalities so that for example I
haven't felt that we've registered quite
excellent reporting which the New York
Times has been doing for several years
now it started with China it's done
extraordinary research clearly this is
an occasion where there's a feeling now
that this should be more discussed but
you know questions come out they norm
the endowments I mean these are key
patrimonial insta
tuitions these are reproducing and you
couldn't decide it's an oligarchy
structure dynastic structure a you know
one-percent structure every day
practically some element of the picture
comes out and yet oddly we don't just
discuss it
the we're just beginning to get
histories of economic thought and yet
you know we perhaps are crossing the
news the other week that only Columbia's
and the others were accepting only 5% of
the students who are applying well what
does that mean you just become a
positional good which is simply a marker
of an elite status it means something
that it goes to five percent at the same
time as the returns on the endowment
goes up to eight or nine percent that
Columbia just finished a campaign where
it receives six point 1 billion dollars
extraordinary which helps restore some
of the endowment well how why is that
coming from abroad what are the
expectations that Columbia could and I
think this is an interesting point
simply recruit across the globe and
leave behind the white you know or
working-class of color in the United
States you know it doesn't up to a point
once it's twenty percent just it needs
twenty percent of athletes and x and y
and z there's still a place for the
reproduction but you know these are
questions which I think the universities
an extraordinary you know offers in the
story store any possibilities and that's
props something you know in the way of
small potatoes but it wouldn't be
pussyfooting around I don't
professor Piketty I just bought your
book today so I just started reading it
so but one thing I was enjoying was your
discussion of Marx and the introduction
and Marx you know I'm sure everybody
knows there was a contradiction in
capitalism between the private ownership
of the means of production and
socialized production and he thought
that that contradiction would be
resolved through social revolution but
what I was going to suggest and ask you
for your reaction is maybe there's a
more pernicious contradiction in
capitalism that Marx missed that
addresses the G that you talk about in
our - G which is if you think of
Bernoulli's log utility curve the people
who live on the far right of the log
utility curve are the people for
whatever reason have the resources to
engage in entrepreneurial activity but
if you look at the at the curve and the
contradiction is they in some sense have
the least incentive to apply those
resources to entrepreneurial activity
and just to give like a stupid
illustration of this we have in the
United States a silly TV show called
Shark Tank
so shark tank is shark tank it's 32,000
submissions a year for people who have
businesses or business ideas and then
they if they get a chance to go before
the entrepreneur of the the rich people
to fund their business ideas now out of
this 32,000 submissions
something like only seventy-five people
a Europe here on the show and maybe
one-third of those get funded and even
though that's a very stupid example I
just wonder if there's a broader this is
taking place in society at a much more
significant level and that the real sort
of first principles approach to trying
to improve things on a large scale is
through resolving
this contradiction between the fact that
people who have all the money really
have no reason to do anything with it
except put it in a hedge fund I have a
question about what might be called as
the reality of capital and based on sort
of the works by Minsky for example who
argue that the more liquidity you have
in a capitalist system or if there's
more liquidity you can set up a positive
spiral where prices of capital goods are
increasing without there really being a
higher rate of return and I was
wondering if I mean there's some people
argue that the last 30 years the
financial sector has made everything
more liquid from mortgages to other
types of assets and that liquidity in
turn is creating these higher prices
which is then in turn giving the Wall
Street bankers higher incomes but we
could wonder how real it is I mean you
could even make the case that we're
living in a thirty-year expansionary
bubble which we keep reinflates I'm it
pops we inflated again and I was
wondering what your view on it and if
that maybe skews the G or the R that we
talked about because there is this sense
that maybe the real rate of return to
capital is decreasing because companies
like Coca Cola are the enemy factories
anymore they're 80 percent branding and
in some sense maybe areata valuations
that we that we have in rates of return
I have to do with you know the financial
system sort of making making this happen
now let me just mention that it is
actually 3:00 a.m. for me in the morning
in Paris and that I think we should stop
this
fantastic discussion if it's okay with
you